Thirty-five percent of the people who use
personal ads for dating are already married.
The Vatican City is the only place in the
world where cash machines offer instructions
in Latin.
To escape the grip of a crocodile's jaws,
push your thumbs into its eyeballs.
It will let you go instantly.
In France, a five year old child can buy an
alcoholic drink in a bar.
It takes a photon 200,000 years to travel
from the core of the Sun to its surface.
Then just a little over 8 minutes to travel
from the Sun's surface to your eyeball.
There is a trash vortex in the Pacific Ocean
known as the Great Pacific garbage patch that
is roughly the size of Texas.
The average person falls asleep in seven minutes.
The national anthem of Greece has 158 verses.
No one in Greece has memorised the entire
anthem.
To date Wikipedia has taken about 100 million
man-hours to create.
Which is actually not a lot when you consider
people in the US alone spend about 1.5 billion
man-hours every month watching TV advertisements.
A rat can last longer without water than a
camel.
One-fifth of the world's doctors are Russian.
There are 293 ways to make change out of a
dollar.
There are only four words in the English language
which end in "dous": tremendous, horrendous,
stupendous, and hazardous.
If you view a bald eagle at a zoo, you are
looking at the American symbol of freedom
in captivity.
If you were to be paid $500 in pennies, you
would actually have enough metal to be melted
down and sold for over $1,000.